die nachrichten des tages heute mit
ein spannende nachrichten tag guten
abend in allen norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei mit neun medaillen ein es
kommt bewegung in die ukraine krise
teilabzug und vorsichtiger optimismus
erste russische panzer verlassen
offenbar das grenzgebiet zur ukraine
kanzler scholz und präsident putin
finden gemeinsame ansätze
ein sehr schmaler grat aktivisten
prangern lebensmittelverschwendung an
blockieren dafür eine autobahn und
machen sich damit strafbar und
mehr geht nicht angeführt von francesco
friedrich holen die deutschen zweierbobs
fahrer gold silber und bronze bei
olympia
es sei die verdammte pflicht und aufgabe
der staats und regierungschefs einen
krieg in europa zu verhindern so der
bundeskanzler heute bei der
pressekonferenz mit pressekonferenz mit
russlands präsident putin nach mehreren
stunden gespräch zuvor hatte moskau mit
einem ersten thronwechsel überrascht es
würde jetzt truppen von der grenze
abziehen
diese bilder des
verteidigungsministeriums in moskau
sollen das belegen
militärtechnik werde verladen und noch
heute kehren laut kreml einige truppen
aus dem westen russlands in ihre
stützpunkte zurück ebenso aus dem
südlichen militär bezirk über den tag in
russland berichtet axel stein der
bundeskanzler hatte schon von kiew aus
ein signal geschickt in richtung moskau
die ukraine käme zur zeit nicht für eine
nato mitgliedschaft in frage scholz
wusste das steuerlich hier gut ankommen
der ton aus dem kreml hat sich geändert
seit gestern abend keine linie natürlich
wollen wir keinen kredit und deshalb
haben wir unsere vorschläge unterbreitet
ein gespräch zu starten das dazu führen
soll dass wir uns über das prinzip der
gleichen sicherheit für alle
einschließlich der von russland einigen
dass diese vorschläge von einer massiven
militärpräsenz begleitet werden sagt
putin nicht stolz kommentiert ich habe
dabei unsere einschätzung meiner
einschätzung der sicherheitslage
erläutert und wie wir unsere
europäischen partner diese entwicklung
bewerten aber auch natürlich den
truppenaufmarsch
als bedrohung empfinden in diesem
zusammenhang kann man gar nicht genug
betonen dass wir sehr besorgt sind was
wohl aus dem 100.000 soldaten und ihren
aktivitäten in nächster zeit werden wird
die können keinen vernünftigen grund für
diese truppen zusammenstellung erkennen
vorher bereits kranzniederlegung am
grabmal des unbekannten soldaten
olaf scholz trifft in moskau ein in
einer woche in der die usa einen angriff
auf die ukraine vorhergesagt hatten
russland sieht seine sicherheit bedroht
und fordert garantien
scholz sieht genug anlass für dialog das
minsker abkommen zum beispiel foren für
gespräche gebe es auch
es liegen eine reihe von ideen vor die
wir nicht nur begrüßen würden zu
besprechen wir haben sie selbst unseren
partnern in den vergangenen jahren auch
vorgeschlagen wir sind bereit zu
weiterer zusammenarbeit
das ist ein satz auf dem hoffnung
wachsen kann und vielleicht auch wegen
dieser bilder angeblich zeigen sie den
rückzug russischer truppen an der grenze
zur ukraine
der bundeskanzler wirkte in moskau für
gespräche und bekommt bereitschaft zu
hören er spricht auch repressionen im
land an die ergebnisse der kanzler reise
an diesem abend anlass zur zuversicht
theo koll hat für uns den bundeskanzler
nach moskau begleitet welchen eindruck
haben sie von dem treffen
nun ich glaube da haben zwei sehr oft
miteinander geredet der kanzler hat
gerade gesagt man habe zum teil
übereinstimmung erlebt aber das heißt im
klartext in wesentlichen hat war man
nicht übereinstimmt dennoch gab es
ansätze in der ukraine ist es so dass
der ukrainische präsident zugesagt hat
gesetzentwürfe vorzulegen die den russen
sehr wichtig sind für die ost ukraine zu
wahlen und zur autonomie es gab die
meldung dass teile der truppen zurück
gezogen werden sehr deutlich wahr man
nicht einer position zur weiteren
entwicklung der nato und was das für die
ukraine bedeutet und dennoch ist es so
da haben zwei sehr offen miteinander
geredet die werden und wurden heute
keine batista gab es keine vornamen da
war man nicht besonders freundlich
miteinander sondern man war klar aber
man war auch klar um von dort aus weiter
zu machen und das ist an sich ein gutes
zeichen jedenfalls so kleines vielen
dank für diese einschätzung aus moskau
theo koll und
das gespräch haben wir unmittelbar vor
der sendung aufgezeichnet
die nato sieht grund zu vorsichtigem
optimismus in der ukraine krise
allerdings nicht wegen der
truppenbewegungen sondern so
generalsekretär stoltenberg wegen
signalen aus moskau das weiter nach
einer diplomatischen lösung gesucht
werden soll die truppenbewegungen vor
ort seien kein zeichen von die
eskalation nach wie vor habe russland
alles in stellung um die ukraine
anzugreifen
fahren wir nach bei unseren kollegen in
der ukraine und in washington zuerst
lothar becker er ist an einem
militärischen stützpunkt in der ukraine
herrscht da insgesamt auch vorsichtiger
optimismus lothar
vorsichtiger optimismus ja aber gepaart
mit einer permanenten alarmbereitschaft
der flugzeuge die hier in mir gott
stationiert sind insgesamt hat es heute
in der ukraine dann doch auch noch mal
etwas spürbare verunsicherung gegeben
als der vorstoß sehr dünner eben die
separatisten gebiete möglicherweise
anerkennen zu wollen seitens russland
der hat ihr natürlich genau einen nerv
getroffen denen man seit acht jahren
sehr schmerzhaft spürt genau das möchte
die ukraine nicht und hat deswegen eine
sehr schnelle zusammenkunft der osze der
staaten des minsker abkommens
eingefordert um eben an dieser frage der
separatisten gebiete in der ost ukraine
direkt konstruktiv weiterzuarbeiten und
nicht mit einer anerkennung durch
russland leben zu müssen
die für russland entscheidenden
verhandlungspartner sind die usa nhc
wissen wie reagiert washington
ja es gibt noch keine offizielle
reaktion aus dem weißen haus das wird
nachher bei pressekonferenzen erfolgen
aber man mutiert notiert hier hinter den
kulissen glaube ich vor allen dingen
zwei dinge von heute diesen treffen
dialogbereitschaft ist etwas was auch
ergebnis der treffen mit an tony blinken
mit emanuele makro auch des
telefongesprächs mit jo jo biden war das
heißt das was wladimir putin gesagt hat
heute ist kein großes zeichen der
hoffnung tatsächlich hat er in der
pressekonferenz ja auch noch mal sehr
klar gemacht dass er von den
grundsatzforderungen was eine mögliche
mitgliedschaft der ukraine in der nato
angeht nicht abrücken wird und das
zweite was man hier notiert ist eben die
frage ob diese teilweisen
truppenbewegungen eine deeskalation
bedeuten da ist man sehr skeptisch man
sieht nämlich gleichzeitig das auf der
krim 60 hubschrauber zusätzlich
stationiert worden sind das ganze
offenbar auch truppen in weißrussland
russische truppen in die gefechts
positionen vorgezogen worden sind also
man ist hier sehr zurückhaltend und man
will selber durch quellen vor ort aber
auch durch aufklärungssatelliten und
aufklärungsflugzeuge herausfinden wie
ernst es putin wirklich mit diesen
truppenabzug und der deeskalation ist
wichtige informationen aus washington
danke schön mrt wissen und lothar becker
ein tag mit viel bewegung im ukraine
konflikt die ganze pressekonferenz von
bundeskanzler scholz und präsident putin
haben wir in unserer zdf heute app
außerdem dort weitere analysen von
fachleuten und unseren korrespondenten
cdu chef friedrich merz übernimmt jetzt
auch den vorsitz der unionsfraktion im
bundestag der 66 jährige bekam
162 der
186 abgegebenen stimmen der
parlamentarier von cdu und csu für märz
geht es jetzt als oppositionsführer die
union neu aufzustellen vorgänger
brinkhaus wollte einen machtkampf
vermeiden und stellte sich nicht mehr
zur wahl
corona da sei der höhepunkt der omicron
welle überschritten sagt
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
nach den zahlen des rk ii ist die sieben
tage ins events am fünften tag in folge
gesunken sie liegt aktuell bei 1400 37,5
morgen beraten bund und länder über
lockerungen nach einer beschlussvorlage
sollen schrittweise bis zum zwanzigsten
märz fast alle maßnahmen fallen bis auf
die masken pflicht schon jetzt sprechen
allerdings erste bundesländer wie bayern
vor andrea maurer hat mehr
dass es ihm nun nicht schnell genug
gehen kann mit ersten öffnungs schritten
diesen eindruck vermittelt der
bayerische ministerpräsident
einen tag vor der bund länder runde hipp
markus söder die kontakt beschränkung
für geimpfte und genesene in seinem
bundesland auf lockert die regeln
wir sind team vorsicht und ihm freiheit
aber nicht team stuhl setzen deswegen
heute auch im bayerischen kabinett
sowohl ein signal in richtung der mpk
aber machen auch unsere eigenen
maßnahmen eigene maßnahmen lockerungs
signale heute auch aus anderen ländern
hamburg kündigt das ende der sperrstunde
in der gastronomie an und auch der
ministerpräsident von schleswig-holstein
will mit seinem öffnungs plan nicht auf
die mpk beschlüsse warten diese schritte
werden wir in jedem fall umsetzen
ich sage dass an der stelle so deutlich
weil wir morgen ja eine konferenz der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundesregierung haben das heißt das ist
unsere positionierung auch dafür es ist
aber unser weg den wir in schleswig
holstein gehen werden klar ist bislang
die rechtsgrundlage für schutzmaßnahmen
im infektionsschutzgesetz läuft am 19
märz aus am 20 märz könnte dann
bundesweit eine art freedom day seien
freiheitstag dass die länder über das
datum hinaus masken pflicht oder notfall
regelungen anordnen können das soll nun
der bundestag rechtlich möglich machen
wenn sich entwickelt ein hotspot eine
bestimmte sehr schwierige lage ist es
wichtig dass wir auch von den ländern
die möglichkeit haben hier sehr zügig zu
reagieren und wir hören signale dass es
dafür auch eine bundesgesetzliche
grundlage geben soll morgen ab 11 uhr 30
mpk am ende des tages wird deutschland
wohl eine öffnung perspektive haben wie
einheitlich die öffnungs schritte
umgesetzt werden das liegt dann in der
hand der ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
für empörung sorgen derzeit immer wieder
demonstranten die bei corona protesten
vor privathäuser von politikern
aufmarschieren zuletzt versuchten
mehrere menschen absperrungen vor dem
wohnhaus von baden württembergs
ministerpräsident kretschmann zu
überwinden gestern abend zogen rund 700
menschen mit fackeln vor das haus des
oberbürgermeisters in halberstadt in
sachsen-anhalt laut polizei wurde der
aufzug maßgeblich von rechtsextremen
angeführt
nach afghanistan vor sechs monaten haben
die taliban dort die macht übernommen
seither hat sich der alltag der menschen
radikal verändert zudem droht vielen der
38 millionen einwohnern eine hungersnot
die lage der wirtschaft ist katastrophal
hilfe zumindest für einige kinder bietet
die aktion friedensdorf unsere
reporterin katrin eigendorf zeigt wie
der ansturm bricht nicht ab eltern
stehen stundenlang schlange mit ihren
schwer kranken kindern voller hoffnung
dass sie hilfe erhalten
claudia papp müller ist mit der
deutschen organisation friedensdorf in
kabul um den familien zu helfen deren
kinder in afghanistan keine chance haben
sie sollen in deutschen kliniken
behandelt werden der achtjährige hast
die bulle hat schwere verbrennungen
erlitten kann seine hände nicht mehr
benutzen er war schon einmal in
deutschland doch braucht eine weitere
operation
es sind dramatische geschichten die die
ärzte hören der 10 jährige abdul rahman
leidet unter einer knochenentzündung er
gehört zu den 80 kindern die im märz
nach deutschland ausgeflogen werden in
afghanistan hätte er keine chance zu
überleben
man sagt immer nimmt mehr mit aber für
mehr mitnehmen müssen wir deutlich mehr
kliniken in deutschland gewinnen für
eine behandlung und die haben wir im
moment nicht und 80 kinder sind 80
kinder nicht gewährt wird gerettet zu
werden so vielen wie möglich eine
zukunftsperspektive zu geben das ist den
mitarbeitern des friedensdorfes ein
wichtiges anliegen
afghanistan braucht dringend mehr
unterstützung fordern einstimmig
internationale hilfsorganisationen doch
die westlichen geberländer stehen vor
einem dilemma wie die bevölkerung
unterstützen ohne die taliban
anzuerkennen dafür werden sie künftig
eine lösung finden müssen wie das
friedensdorf kehren angesichts der
dramatischen lage immer mehr private
zurück ihnen haben die taliban
sicherheit und unterstützung zugesagt
ein meer aus kerzen und blumen ein
ausdruck der tiefen trauer nach dem mord
an einer jungen polizistin und ihren
kollegen ende januar in rheinland pfalz
heute wurde der 29 jährige polizist in
seiner heimatstadt freisen beerdigt
unter großer anteilnahme der bevölkerung
er und seine kollegin eine 24 jahre alte
polizeianwärterin waren auf einer
landstraße bei kusel erschossen worden
die mutmaßlichen täter wollten offenbar
ihre wilderei vertuschen
seit einigen wochen sorgen sie für
aufsehen und genau das ist auch das ziel
der klima- aktivisten der gruppe
aufstand der letzten generation sie
blockieren autobahnen starten eine
pflanzen aktion am kanzleramt sie
fordern ein gesetz gegen
lebensmittelverschwendung und die
agrarwende doch ihre drastischen
proteste stoßen auf kritik aber gehört
hat mir
autobahnabfahrt freiburg nord
aktivistinnen haben ihre hände auf den
asphalt geklebt wie schon bei protesten
in berlin sie sehen sich als letzte
generation die die klimakrise noch
verhindern kann wir muten den
autofahrern autofahren schon viel zu das
ist uns klar wir sind einfach gerade
keine andere möglichkeit um dem thema
die aufmerksamkeit zu geben die es
wirklich braucht gerade mit radikalen
methoden ums klima kämpfen spd und fdp
verurteilen dass die grünen ringen um
ihre position erst zeigen teile der
partei verständnis mittlerweile
überwiegt die kritik proteste müssen
friedlich sein sie dürfen niemanden
gefährden und menschen die autobahn
zugänge blockieren den kann ich nicht
unterstellen dass sie niemanden
gefährden und deswegen finden die unsere
unterstützung nicht von autobahn
blockaden halte ich mal gar nichts
und ich will dass es nicht geht es in
schwere
rechtsverletzung
die man nicht rechtfertigen kann
ein zeichen für eine generelle
radikalisierung der klimabewegung sieht
protestforscher moritz sommer in den
blockaden nicht wenn wir uns anschauen
wie viele beides für future
beispielsweise in den letzten jahren vor
der pandemie vor allem auf die straße
gebracht haben da sind es doch jetzt
sehr vereinzelte stimmen und vereinzelte
persönlichkeiten die da eben zu diesen
mitteln des protests greifen trotz
massiver kritik die letzte generation
will weiter straßen blockieren bis die
politik ein gesetz gegen
lebensmittelverschwendung zumindest in
aussicht stellt
ein skandal im britischen königshaus ist
offenbar an sein juristisches ende
gekommen der mit missbrauchs- vorwürfen
konfrontierte prinz andrew hat sich mit
der klägerin virginia geoffrey auf einen
außergerichtlichen vergleich geeinigt
dass schrieb ihr anwalt dem gericht
geoffrey hatte dem sohn von queen
elizabeth dem zweiten vorgeworfen sie
vor gut 20 jahren als minderjährige
mehrfach sexuell missbraucht zu haben
sie sei vom us geschäftsmann jeffrey
epstein und dessen ex partnerin gelang
max will dazu gezwungen worden
so und jetzt machen wir einen ganz
harten schnitt und machen ein dreifaches
hurra für den historischen
dreifach-erfolg uns aber ja das erste
mal überhaupt in der olympischen bob
geschichte dass eine nation den
kompletten medaillensatz gewinnt gold
silber bronze erneut überragend im
eiskanal rekord weltmeister francesco
friedrich so überlegen wie kein pilot in
den letzten drei jahrzehnten gewinn
francesco friedrich sein drittes olympia
gold wir sind so stolz auf uns
gegenseitig wir wir haben das einfach
heute gerockt im ersten lauf und dass
wir uns so wichtig und das wollten wir
genauso machen und das ist genauso
gelungen friere ich hatte für die
letzten beiden läufe extra nochmal den
bock gewechselt um ganz sicher den sieg
einzufahren und baute seinen vorsprung
auf johannes lochner auf 0,49 sekunden
aus den deutschen dreifacherfolg im
eiskanal von jäntsch in komplettierte
christoph hafer auf platz drei
ansonsten war es heute für das team
deutschland der tag der knapp verpassten
medaille etwa in der nordischen
kombination olympia debütant manuel
faißt lag zeitweise sogar auf goldkurs
am ende reichte es nur für platz vier er
hat gekämpft und keine schwächen
zugelassen und so kurz vor dem ziel die
medaille noch fest im blick aber dennoch
das treppchen knapp verpasst
aber danach sieht es aus nürnberg
gewinnt der 29 jährige deutsche hatte
vorher im springen überragende 133 meter
ins tal gebracht und konnte als vierter
in das 10 kilometer rennen gehen waren
super sprüngen von mir und lauf war ich
auch ziemlich gut hat in der letzten
runde noch so genug körner wie es mir
vorgestellt habe aber ja leider ist
jetzt der vierte platz geworden aber
klar eine muss auch vierter werden
vinzenz geiger ist nach einem eher
verkorksten sprung aber tollen lauf am
ende siebter gold gewinnt jürgen groh
berg aus norwegen
ja und ebenfalls auf dem undankbaren
vierten platz landeten heute keira
knightley ski abfahrts rennen der frauen
und die deutsche biathlon-staffel der
männer
es ist das letzte schießen bei dem die
nerven von philipp nawrath versagen er
kassiert eine strafrunde und damit
platzt die große medaillen traum der
deutschen biathleten in der staffel gold
gewinnen die norweger es ist ein schrei
der enttäuschung von kira weigel der 25
jährigen gelingt eine schnelle fast
fehlerfreie abfahrt doch am ende reicht
es nicht für die so ersehnte medaille
weiter wird vierte gold geht an die
schweizerin corinne suter ein frühes
ende für ein schwaches deutsche
eishockey-team auch sie waren mit großer
medaillen hoffnung gestartet im spiel um
das viertelfinale kassieren sie mit 0 zu
vier eine deftige niederlage gegen die
slowakei der silber coup von führen kann
bleibt somit vorerst einzigartig
das wassersport
das wird ein regnerischer mittwochmorgen
und dann kommt der sturm worauf sie sich
einstellen müssen erfahren wie gleich
von katja honnefer passieren sie was
begrüßt sie eben heute journal um
21.45 wir sagen tschüss und bis morgen
auf wiedersehen
ist
[Musik]
guten abend in den kommenden 24 stunden
überqueren uns gleich mehrere regen
bender es wird sehr mild und den ersten
höhepunkt der kommenden sturm lage
erwarten wir für donnerstag früh in
dieser nacht ist es noch vergleichsweise
ruhig es fällt häufig regen ab und zu
ist doch etwas schnee in den
mittelgebirgen dabei im südosten ist das
dagegen zum teil klar und so sinken die
temperaturen am alpenrand auf plus 1 bis
minus 5 grad sonst bleibt die nacht bei
8 bis 3 grad milder und morgen erwarten
uns höchsttemperaturen von 6 grad an den
alpen und bis zu 14 grad am niederrhein
und dazu fällt häufig regen allenfalls
in niederbayern haben sie vormittags
noch ein bisschen chancen auf
sonnenschein dann kommt die nacht auf
donnerstag und dann nimmt der wind böig
zu donnerstag früh erwarten wir auch
kahn böen mit mehr als 117 kilometer pro
stunde zum beispiel im harz orkanartige
sturmböen an den küsten und schwere
sturmböen im alpenvorland meiden sie
wälder halten sie sich von baugerüsten
fern und vielleicht sollten sie auch
reisen vermeiden oder ändern am
donnerstag gibt es kräftige schauer am
freitag kommt dann sogar ein orkantief
heran und am samstag hat sich der
warmluft orkan dann ausgedruckt guten
abend